the evil's growing it's coming
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks
well folks welcome everybody something
very strange is happening with the
intros
this happened once before and for the
life of me
it took me days to figure out what it
was
and it's something about what's set to
monitor only and what's monitor and
output it and i don't know why every
once in a while
um the settings just
go crazy and i don't know what it is
well welcome listen this is the rare
sunday stream
and the reason i'm here is there is such
corrosive to democracy breaking news
about scrumps and everything else going
on in this country there's no way i'm
even possibly going to be able to get to
everything on tomorrow's uh
even if i included the bonus show in the
entire thing
um there is just no way
that i would have time to cover
everything so we're here today uh
because there are so many things to talk
about we are of course going to talk
about the espionage stuff we are
monitoring cnn about the recovered
documents we are monitoring fox news we
are monitoring newsmax as well
um and really quite frankly the entire
thing let's listen
very briefly to what's happening on cnn
while i get everything else set up but
there is so much to discuss today super
chats are dumping in let's take a quick
listen
well those are exactly the questions
that people are asking so let's get
right to the massive massive breaking
news the fbi search warrant shows donald
trump
oh there was no audio you guys couldn't
hear that oh i could hear that hold on
let's let's fix that let's fix that hold
on
this will be useful
olivia uh let me ask you about this a
top republican on the house intelligence
committee can you hear it now i'm very
vocal in casting doubt on this fbi
search um i want to get your reaction to
this exchange that congressman mike
turner had this morning
we're getting technical elements worked
out we're gonna get to the mike turner
stuff momentarily thank you everybody
i am not trolling guys genuinely i every
once in a while this happens and i don't
get why
but we've resolved it okay
fbi search warrant shows trump under
investigation for potential obstruction
of justice and espionage act violations
now this doesn't literally mean trump is
a
blank spy
russian spy swedish spy
danish spy argentinian spy chilean spy
rwandan spy sierra leone's spy no what
we're saying is
we are talking about
espionage
elements
without him necessarily being a spy for
someone okay look at this
a search warrant newly unsealed
reveals
the fbi is investigating donald trump
for a potential violation of the
espionage act
and that agents removed classified
documents from trump's estate earlier
this week
folks
they keep saying oh this is
unprecedented
this is unprecedented well
when the president does
unprecedented things
then you are going to see unprecedented
consequences
it is that simple
and they continue to repeat no but
they've never done anything to any
president before
what president deserved it they're
talking about nobody raided obama
well what did obama do that would
deserve a raid
obama gate which still hasn't even been
defined
they never raided hillary
hillary testified under oath for eight
hours
and there were was it 11 investigations
into benghazi
this is unprecedented because we've
never had a president behave in this way
also among the items taken from
mar-a-lago an item labeled executive
grant of clemency for roger jason stone
jr
stone ultimately was pardoned
the warrant shows federal law
enforcement was investigating trump for
removal or destruction of records
obstruction of justice and yes ladies
and gentlemen
violating the espionage act
which encompasses crimes beyond spying
espionage
is more than the individual act of
spying
sometimes it's done electronically we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines there you go
it can be
machinery espionage
industrial
providing information having information
all these different things
conviction under the statutes can result
in imprisonment or fines now
if you actually add it all up
the potential
prison time for the things trump's being
investigated for is 33 years we will be
talking about that on the podcast
tomorrow 33 years
potentially hasn't even been charged
folks so everybody relax
couple of uh super chats can you ask the
moderators to reinstate weather on
nightbot
uh yeah i don't know that i don't know
anything about why it was removed but
it's a little bit annoying i mean we you
know
you could just look up the weather i
don't know that we need weather in the
chat necessarily
elements of sound says ezra after
pleading the fifth what needs to happen
for trump to be held legally responsible
for financial crimes well first up would
be an indictment
argentinian spy is my new band name says
adam gingrich very much very very well
said now here is one of the absolute
funniest things about this whole thing
trump is now asking for the documents to
be returned
first it was there were no documents and
the fbi planted them
now it's please give us back
the documents oh hold on i gotta ban a
few people
um
wow folks
the trolls are furious that the channel
has exploded lately and that we're
rapidly approaching 1.5 million youtube
subscribers and a hundred thousand
twitch subscribers
um
and the trolls are going
nuts absolutely and completely nuts and
we've got to be banning them moderators
please uh we are not tolerating this
today okay
or any other day
we're just not doing it
so the documents that were planted by
the fbi originally now trump wants them
back look at this oh great
it has just been learned that the fbi
in its now famous raid of mar-a-lago
took boxes of privileged attorney-client
material also executive privileged
material which they knowingly should not
have taken by copy of this truth i
respectfully request these documents be
immediately returned to the location
from which they were taken so wait was
the only stuff the fbi took stuff they
planted or now you're saying they
actually did take stuff that was there
oh they planted some stuff and took so
many oh okay i get it i get it
very very that makes a lot of sense
donald
every five minutes
there is a new explanation which
contradicts the previous one
um
[Music]
i know i'm missing some thank yous and
i'm going to get to them in a moment
the trolls are really out in force
i posted this to my twitter earlier
here's a message i got today from dwayne
see if you can make any sense out of
this
uh hold on let's see if i can go full sp
it's not really visible
hold on a second
hmm okay i'll have to read it to you oh
wait let's see uh
see if i do just the image ah there we
go okay let's zoom it in
here's a message i got
here's the this is the subject okay
first of all putting a paragraph in the
subject is already a red flag okay
david when trump is house speaker can
you make sure you run the butt hurt
cream
but make sure you rub it all over
sec
they didn't have jones phone going two
years back
i hope you see how full of [ __ ] the
media is
is that progressive
sent from my iphone
uh i don't know what point dwayne is
making i really don't
i don't know what he's trying to achieve
and we will ban
men well maybe i don't it doesn't seem
necessarily gender oriented i'm not sure
so
questionable literacy yes
questionable literacy very very much
uh okay i want to look with you now
at an absolutely incredible interview
cnn's brianna keeler interviewed
congressman mike turner my congressman
mike turner is a bomb throwing
republican who i believe is the guy that
a couple days ago said something like
well you know
there's lots of categories of nuclear of
classified nuclear documents and some of
them aren't really filled with that
classified of information absolutely
crazy he went on and was interviewed by
cnn's briana keeler and it really did
not go well for him before i play this
for you i let me just get caught up on
thank yous i want to say thanks to
marina wells who just signed up on my
website and his new member number one
today also thank you to jason sickmeyer
who just gifted a membership on my
website and is number two and over on
twitch thanks to cody frank
lilika microkimi
hendrix
small fuzzy moss
melangel
dave schmidt
all signing up via twitch prime uh
putting us at nine for the day and yes
folks the coupon code indict saves you
like 60
off of memberships on my website and we
do really appreciate those and today on
this rare sunday stream
would be a perfect perfect day
to get one of those memberships all
right let's jump right in to the briana
keeler interview this is really good
stuff really really good talking about
in these documents at mar-a-lago and
you've learned that doj is investigating
possible espionage act violations are
you concerned that donald trump was
keeping this highly classified documents
these highly classified documents at his
resort
well we have a number of concerns
brianna obviously you know one is
whether or not the raid itself was was
justified okay so first of all this is
called deflection
we have a search warrant
we know the process
we know that merrick garland signed off
on it we know trump's own selection for
fbi director christopher wray signed off
on it and we know that a judge signed
off on it so we don't have any reason
right now to believe that there was no
legal justification
they should now prove there was no legal
justification but all of the evidence so
far
is that this was you know who was it
that said it hannity eyes crossed and
t's dotted for lack of a better term of
this list from the fbi but we don't have
conclusive as to whether this actually
is classified material and whether or
not it right second
distortion
the things some of the things trump is
being investigated for
doesn't depend
on whether the information was
classified so in
it's we're 30 seconds in turner's been
speaking for eight seconds
he's already told two
very deceptive things sizes to the level
the highest classified material on a
bipartisan basis congress is saying show
us the goods we want to know one what
did the department of justice and the
fbi tell the judge that they were going
to find and what did they find there's
nothing in those boxes that members of
the intelligence community and commit
and the committee itself don't have the
ability to see if it rises to the level
of an immediate national security threat
which is what it would take to to
actually raid the president's home
because you know they remember
the term raid
is very
uh suggestive and salacious
a search warrant was executed you know
and and i i'm guilty of this as well
execution of a search warrant
there is this shorthand the word raid
they executed a search warrant right
okay they had a number of options
available to them including just going
to court and asking for the courts to
enforce the subpoena that they had
now
clearly um no one is above the law
donald trump is not above the law and
attorney general garland is not above
the law either and uh congress has the
powers of oversight he needs to comply
we've seen material like this before
we've seen materials that have been uh
submitted to courts for uh for warrants
this is not unprecedented his actions
are so just i know you guys probably
don't remember the question the question
was whether mike turner's concerned
about the materials that donald trump
had at mar-a-lago
so this is this is a real splat on the
wall to see what sticks unprecedented
history and he has a lot of questions to
answer
you're familiar
with special access programs
and the level of classification that is
why are you casting doubt on how
classified this information was
if you see the property receipt and it's
very good question very clear that this
was sci information some of it and i'm
going to answer it honestly for you guys
the answer is
if you don't like the content you
question process
and if you don't like the process you
question the con i'm sorry let me put a
different way if if you don't like the
content you question the process
and if the content is good for you you
focus on the content that's the way they
operate
well but but what that receipt shows is
that this material was marked as such it
doesn't mean that it currently is i can
get
[Laughter]
listen
all the documents had top secret
classified written all over them that's
not proof that they were give you an
example for you know zawahiri
we were giving briefings and briefing
materials
concerning the hunt for zawahiri
all of the issues of trying to find
zawahiri how they found zawahiri today
you know those that information it's
been broadcast on your own news channel
but yet if you go down into the skiff of
the intelligence committee we'll still
have materials that are still marked uh
classified tsi uh similarly you know the
russian anti-satellite weapons we have
classified materials that are marked as
classified again the question really is
do you're now saying maybe that all this
stuff wasn't truly classified
but do you have evidence of that
or you're just trying to
distort but yet you yourself have
broadcast
those these are materials that are two
years old we don't know what they are we
don't know if they rise to the level of
being a national security threat but the
fact that you have here the attorney
general who is going after the you know
president biden's political rival whose
own
personal career was derailed on the way
to the supreme court by donald trump
himself an unequal application of a law
between hillary clinton and donald trump
there is no
that that is that is untrue now i don't
want to do a legal analysis that is
beyond me
numerous legal experts have explained
why the hillary clinton email thing is
completely different than this hillary
clinton's email server
was disclosed
it was investigated
there were not crimes it was
investigated by a republican-led fbi
that it it's just not the same thing
there was nothing to go and obtain
hillary wasn't um uh refusing to turn
things over it it's just not the same
thing and um
brianna some people are saying brianna
keeler's not controlling the interview
well this guy is gish galloping i do
think overall she does a pretty good job
and the fact that you have the fbi
previously submitted
in warrants uh more materials that were
bogus that were political politically
motivated that targeted donald trump
there's a high level of skepticism but
we don't have to speculate we have the
clearance we have the the oversight
ability attorney general garland needs
to provide these materials we have
bipartisan calls for do that put the
materials in a room let us see them and
then we can tell you what our answer is
and what our you know discernment is
of whether or not this is a true
national security threat or whether or
not this is an abusive discretion now
remember they the the house is not
a law enforcement body they can refer to
law enforcement
actions which they believe could be
crimes
but this is all just completely
backwards by attorney general garland do
you take home documents marked special
access
no
and yet you're casting down and you know
quite frankly you know i've been i i've
been in the oval office um with the
president and i'd be very surprised if
he has actual documents at rise to level
an immediate national security threat
that's not the issue though did you did
you guys see that switcheroo
she asked about whether he takes home
documents with a certain classification
that is very it's that's objective does
it have a certain classification turner
goes
i just don't know that those documents
were really of of national security
importance well that's a judgment call
that's not the question that brianna
asked this was a very bad idea for
turner to do this interview
well the documents just to be clear
several sets and you're aware of that
because you've seen the property receipt
you're casting doubt you want
information you don't actually have that
information on which to base that
conclusion at this point correct but you
yourself would not take home documents
that are marked special access you would
not take home this sensitive
compartmented information
well remember what i'm casting doubt on
i mean it's not
these are labeled that we don't know
whether or not these are are classified
and rise to level but this listen
it has
a radiation warning on it
we don't know that it's really
radioactive we just don't we just don't
know that anything can be labeled
radioactive oh interesting second thing
we don't know is are they a national
security threat attorney general garden
now now understand
brianna keeler hasn't even brought up
national security threat at this point
that's a separate issue
could have gone you know they're going
to enforce the subpoena do you know do
you know they're not asking the court to
demand that donald trump deliver now
here i actually can't tell whether he
can't hear her or he's pretending that
he can't hear her for the materials to
the court and said he spent nine hours
in his home that rises to the highest
level we give them authority to be
intrusive and invasive and that's to be
used sparingly because there are other
options that are available to
spent
him
hours in trump's residence they're gonna
have to justify that they had concern
this could be a national security threat
when you cast out on that do you have
evidence
that this was not a national right the
people with all the evidence and and
information worried that it was a
national security threat he has none of
it and is casting doubt on it security
threat it's sort of like when cassidy
hutchinson testified under oath and then
like through the grapevine supposedly
some secret service agent was willing to
dispute what she said but then when they
were invited to come in and do it under
oath they didn't
or that this was known
actually to the point and i'm sorry
you're breaking up a bit for me but we
don't he's struggling to hear her at
this critical moment i have to speculate
uh we have all the clearance congress
has all the powers of oversight all
attorney garland has to do is comply
with the laws provide this information
to us let us look show us the goods
bipartisan basis people are calling for
the attorney general garland show us the
goods you're breaking up like it's some
kind of phone connection we need to
determine is this a national security
threat and as we also determine that is
was there abuse of discretion by
attorney general garland so oh the issue
is whether we should jail garland that's
interesting that's a good turnaround
you're awaiting that information that
you would like to get from doj you
mentioned hillary clinton i would like
to read a couple of things this is re
this is a really good part here that you
said about hillary clinton's emails in
2016. you said quote in may of that year
hillary clinton would be an awful
president as she has shown a blatant
disregard for our laws you said former
secretary of state clinton has put our
national security at risk by showing a
blatant disregard for highly sensitive
classified information in october you
said i believe her actions as secretary
of state were not in accordance with the
law some of your comments were said
before it was even clear what was in her
emails you're not holding donald trump
to the same standard why
oh because i'm a partisan hack brianna
imagine if a republican ever actually
answered the question in that way
it would be absolutely historic
it would be an historic moment well
brianna i'm a complete idiot partisan
hack and every one of my stated
principles is only a principle for as
long as it's convenient here it's not so
i'm actually just saying the opposite of
what i've said for my entire career
well there are there's a significant
difference here one there was active
transmission of ongoing diplomatic
classified communications that were
traveling through hillary clinton's
server in her residence which innately
and inherently are going to be a risk
these are two-year-old documents that
are in the president's residence we
don't know what's in them uh they're not
ongoing
certainly now which if you don't know
what's in them how do you know they're
not relevant things that are ongoing
how does that make any sense
they waited two years
after they got there do you have
evidence
sir do you have evidence that they are
not on
communications that you had hillary all
of a sudden she's breaking up again guys
clinton but remember they did not rate
hillary clinton's home this is why this
is why hill this is why garland has got
to answer these questions it's unequal
application of the law they did not
raise how do you know
how do you know it's unequal application
of the law if you still don't actually
know what's in the documents how would
you possibly know that nine hours in his
home excuse me sir sir i just want to be
clear how do you know they're not
ongoing you haven't been
briefed on what you want to be briefed
on he's complaining he has no clue what
this is in the documents
and he's saying these documents are
completely different and here's the
reason why
how do you know that
why are you saying that according to the
receipt according well we do know it and
even you know it and you and i can both
agree that the inventory itself lists
papers
that were taken from his home in boxes
papers are static they're not ongoing uh
data communications and uh do are you
concerned that these papers might
contain the nuclear codes
listen
papers are made from
wood pulp
and when you go out into these forests
sometimes they're not raking the forest
floor and brianna i want to put
partisanship aside you and i can agree
trees go grow from seedlings that we can
agree on completely and the thing about
it is we just don't know when else has
paper been used and what kinds of trees
does it come from
right no that wasn't the question
transmissions of data which is what was
going through hillary clinton's server
remember they did not raid his her home
they raided his home you're talking
about the information clearly but what
you were talking about is the
information itself and whether it is
still classified or whether it is still
a national security risk
no i was not talking about that i was
talking about the manner of transmission
and and the timeliness what it wrote
that wasn't at all what they were
talking about
that wasn't even close to the
conversation represent
as classified information now as you
know also what you didn't report donald
trump says he declassified these
materials no one questions that the
president uh former president would have
had as president the authority to
declassify that material he didn't
and with some of these documents their
classification is not actually the issue
this is more subterfuge so it is
possible that you yourself can see all
this material and i know cnn will be
demanding i'm sure as you demanded that
the warrant and the affidavit be
released to you um i'm certain that if
it's declassified which is a fact-based
uh you know issue that's going to have
to be also resolved you yourself will
want to see these documents how do they
rise to the level how do why does it
matter what he keeps making it about
brianna
he's like brianna
you're going to want to see these
documents
so there
oh wow okay
because you have to agree
when the fbi chooses the most intrusive
the most invasive process of invading a
man's home when they have available to
their other options i just want to be
clear
these are classified documents the
former president trump deliver the
doctors these are classified documents
that that transmission glitch is
happening again where he can't hear what
she's breaking up guys invasive has to
be concerned to you also
there are a number of steps they took
before we have a graphic to show people
of the timeline of the other steps they
took leading up to it i just want to be
clear they didn't jump from nothing to
go into this search and seizure now i
want to mention one other thing folks
because this is going to be a big topic
in the information war that
is going to kick up tomorrow
they want to have this argument both
ways ben shabibo
was on twitter talking about this
saying listen
if this was so urgently a national
security risk
why did they take all these steps and
only now serve the search warrant
if it was that urgent
look at all these different steps it
couldn't have been that urgent because
they took this much time
and of course
if the fbi and doj had not done all
these things on the screen
the very same people would be saying
this is a president and you don't even
work through his lawyers you don't even
give him the opportunity to comply
that's insanely aggressive behavior we
this is a president you have to allow
the system to work
either way they would be complaining
about steps taken or not
and the amount of time taken or not and
i'm going to tell you right now guys
we are we are banning dozens of people
because there are toxic losers invading
the chat and we're going to keep doing
that okay
just to be clear are you saying that the
where they were kept was secure
no i have i have no idea these are
questions attorney garland is going to
have to answer it the question is not
did they jump and you know were they
doing other things the question is what
did they do in between they had other
options i'm certain that you have to
understand that going into his house
especially the former president
president biden's political rival into
his house for nine hours as the most
intrusive invasive and attorney
garland's got to justify that congress
has the authority of power of oversight
he needs to tell us what is a
justification show us these documents we
have the clearance to see them he needs
to show us the goods
i do want to ask you the former
president's social media network put out
a push alert promoting a story from a
conservative outlet that identified the
fbi agents involved in this search
and this comes after an armed man tried
to enter an fbi office in cincinnati
with an ar-15 assault rifle he was
killed in the process of that how is
that not encouraging violence against
federal law enforcement officers in this
climate to identify them
well obviously i don't know who you're
referring to didn't see the story
brianna not sure what you're talking
about the media but but resoundly
congress has condemned any violence
against any members of congress have
condemned and i did and all of the
republican members of my committee
jointly in a joint press conference
condemned any violence against
any law enforcement officers and in fact
said that we greatly appreciate we
greatly appreciate the service this
guy's voice is like a more annoying mitt
romney all of our fbi agents men and
women who are serving their nation
should the president former president
i i think always everyone should make it
very clear that this is not an issue
where violence is ever an answer i think
you should make it very clear right
brianna why won't you tell your audience
that violence is not the answer you and
trump have the same responsibility to
denounce the violence and to prevent the
violence now okay trump's the one who
got the search warrant served and
trump's the one who's out there
fomenting talk of civil war but brianna
you you must use your position to make
sure people know
not to use violence this is not
something that that that should rise to
the level of violence this is an issue
where show us the goods attorney garland
you have to follow the law just as
donald trump has to follow law congress
has oversight and the the full ability
to see these documents
justified that you went into this man's
house for nine hours nine
okay that's it that's the interview and
so
listen i mean it wasn't like fireworks
but
not answering any of the questions and
brianna keeler doing a reasonably good
job of at least trying to to stay on the
reality that he's trying to have it both
ways
we're not being told what's in these
documents and based on what's in these
documents here's a bunch of opinions
but you said you don't know what's in
them right no but we've got the receipts
oh so then you do know what's in there
no we're not being given any
transparency and merit garland has to
explain why aren't we seeing the
documents come on dude
big big big time loser so that's that's
that
um
here's the other issue and they're
covering it on cnn right now about the
threat the fbi now remember back the
blue thin blue line
oh now it's go and attack and threaten
fbi agents please follow the russians
follow one of the most horrific things
in america that is cyber pornography
against infants if you think they can
follow white-collar crime if you think
they can follow mortgage fraud that is
not a state local problem you may object
to what happened in mar-a-lago but if
you say
defund the fbi let your kid be abused by
an adult
that's what the fbi does good luck jim
yeah no it doesn't add up it's not it's
not a realistic proposal and it seems to
be made when donald trump gets himself
into hot water that's when they want to
go after federal law enforcement and and
speaking of which we know that the
unredacted search warrant was leaked uh
meaning the names of these agents uh who
are involved are are out there uh what
they're dock guys the people who support
the police are doxing fbi agents imagine
that this gets leaked and the agent's
names and and so on it gets doxed
so let me step you through what happens
you've got to go home to your spouse or
your girlfriend and your children
and you tell them my name is leaked and
people who might want to commit an act
of violence might come to our home
you've got to go to your workplace and
say should we stay at home and our kids
are going back to school it's august
kids are going back to school what do i
do will you provide me with the security
will the government provide security how
long will they provide it for it's not
just about people who want to commit an
act of violence against an fbi agent i
would ask them to consider
do you want to walk home to your family
and your spouse and say
look over your shoulder all right you
get the idea it's dangerous it's
dangerous we get it and it's absolutely
predictable it's completely and totally
predictable
um all right meanwhile what is happening
over on fox news i'm curious what
explosive stories they're covering today
uh during some kind of a break okay so
we will keep an eye on that and then
over on newsmax
mulvaney believes the fbi informant is
really close to trump yeah that very
much that very much could be
that very much could be all right let's
continue looking at a few other things
um oh before we do let me get caught up
and thank everybody who's been
supporting the stream first of all
welcome to jeff heinzman
laura emerson
and taylor thompson the three of you
signed up for memberships at
joinedpakman.com and i really appreciate
that
terry schwerin rachel klein sean fertill
another rachel klein and kevin gouldy
have each gifted a membership at
jointpakman.com if you want a free
membership on my website go to
davidpakman.com free membership and fill
out the form about 800 people right now
are waiting for free memberships it is a
long list but we're working through them
okay
if you want to sign up for a membership
i would love for you to do that today
if you go to my website joinpakman.com
we're a viewer supported program okay
many of us between internet
and spotify
and all these different things we might
pay 50 100 200 a month mostly for stuff
we don't like if you have a cable
subscription four bucks a month goes to
fox news okay
the suggestion here is
a couple bucks a month could go directly
to the david pakman show actually
supports something you hopefully like
now a lot of you in the chat don't like
this you're here to troll and many of
you are getting banned like for example
one person just says what causes your
left wing disease david they are banned
and they will never be allowed to chat
again here okay
just get out
but for those of you who do like what we
are doing i would love for you to sign
up on my website joinpakman.com it's
quick it's easy you can use the coupon
code indict and it will be dirt dirt
dirt cheap uh also of course twitch
subscriptions are welcome
and i'm gonna thank a few people
bulbasaurus bo staff the dragon clown
and guitar goddess all signing up via
twitch prime putting us at 21. the goal
is a hundred it's a random sunday stream
but there seems to be some interest in
what's going on uh about 17 18 000 folks
watching fortunately across our various
platforms and people are getting banned
at an unbelievable rate at an
unbelievable rate a couple other super
chats i'm a trans left-leaning
blockchain startup founder would love
the opportunity to be interviewed if
you're interested let me know what email
my publicist can send an inquiry to that
would go through our sponsored content
channel yes
we those those are sponsored interviews
and we make that very very clear
um so you can use info davidpakman.com
love and support from toronto also
joined on the website just to tell the
trolls leave our beautiful stream alone
we don't need you here
beautifully said absolutely beautifully
said okay
let's continue because i have so many
other things i'm going to tell you every
once in a while there's some
content creator that i think is
interesting and i want to recommend to
you okay
the other day
youtube recommended to me
the office drummer
i don't know if it's because i sometimes
watch drumming videos because i play
drums or what
so i checked out the office drummer
i went to
his twitch
and said hello in the chat
an office drummer knew who i was
said he was a fan
i am recommending to you office drummer
this is a small
creator for now 26 000 followers on
twitch
only a thousand subscribers on youtube
he dresses like a
[Music]
very uh what's the word generic office
worker i guess i would say and does
streams where he just takes requests and
plays drums let's look at one popular
video
uh let's see what what do we want to
look at
i don't know maybe
maybe some green day this guy's good i
like this guy putting w's in the chat if
you guys are enjoying the show thank you
for being here i really appreciate it
do you have the time look at this guy
i love it
i am one of those
melodramatic [ __ ]
[Music]
also beautiful miking job on the drums
like it's just everything's good about
it
[Music]
[Music]
okay anyway you guys get it so that's
office drummer check them out on um on
twitch office drummer check them out on
youtube as well again small channel
only a thousand subscribers this is the
thing
make sure in the chat in this in the
comments to tell them david pakman sent
you that's the thing we're bombing him
all right very good so let's continue
um other things that i wanted to play
for you this is absolutely fantastic
stuff i hope you guys will appreciate
this john bolton is a disgusting human
being absolutely disgusting
uh warmongering neocon architect of the
iraq war just absolutely horrible
however
he every once in a while says something
that's accurate and he went to uh eric
balling's show on newsmax
and he made the case listen
we're much safer under joe biden i mean
bolton is a disgusting right-wing nut
but he said we're safer under biden than
under trump
eric bolling was so
triggered that it is a pleasure to watch
this check this out this is all of
course
related to the search warrant at
mar-a-lago oral could you think that
we're safer now than we were under
president trump when he was willing to
put missiles into syrian air bases with
russians on the base
what's going on here sir he didn't
understand
because he didn't understand
fundamentally much of anything about
international affairs true who who could
argue trump understood international
affairs perfectly accurate so far his
decisions were not based on a coherent
philosophy or there was no philosophy
that's absolutely correct the philosophy
was
what's good for me today that i can
justify our coherent power
you know what made us less safe is when
biden pulled us out of afghanistan 13
americans died and now this trump
stealing and now the taliban tells us
back off don't the the the belly
laughter is my favorite moment in the
entire thing and when it happens look at
eric balling's face looks like it's
about to burst look at the size of that
guy's cheeks
now that he's all fired up he did not
like the belly laugh and that's what
really triggers him let's go back a few
seconds the belly i mean it's in don't
get me wrong
this is an evil laugh like this is the
laugh i imagine john bolton doing
as they're invading iraq this he's
disgusting okay
but it triggers
balling in a way that is and guys
nobody's championing john bolton okay so
that that can go in the chat nobody's
championing john bolton
all right check this out start and that
was trump steven and now the taliban
tells us back off don't kill
al-qaeda right
are you out of your mind
the laugh triggers are you out of your
mind saying they would
by the way balling is orange and bolton
is completely red i don't know if that's
a white balance issue or what
no oh who who cut the deal eric
who cut the deal who delivered the deal
no no
eric you don't know what you're talking
about he wanted everybody
disagrees with you we don't know what
we're talking about trump said leave
2500 until we have a smooth training
trump said that after the fact look he
said that after he cut the deal
exactly yeah exactly the deal cut us
down to zero that's what trump wanted he
wanted everybody out the record on that
is completely clear over time biden
pulled him out well with americans still
there the best read the deal eric have
you ever read the deal i'll stop it yeah
i know you gotta go before you're
embarrassed even further
look at his face right now oh dear god
look at his face he did not like that oh
my god
get out of here you get abort abort
abort before you embarrass yourself even
more
bolton is horrible guys but this is just
so good because of the degree to which
balling is triggered here
delightful just really a pleasure really
really a pleasure to watch even the look
on bolton's face is pretty good
um
it is gold nobody's championing john
bolton guys nobody everybody just relax
nobody here is championing john bolton
but that was very very well done
and extraordinarily enjoyable i have to
say
thank you to vivolf cola scr the
darkness rich
iron chef latisha coder
doomkatz and yeta that's one two three
four five six seven eight
twitch prime subscribers over on the
website i do wanna say thank you
to some extraordinary people david
shaffer is a new member
keith jacobson
just signed up
keith thank you for signing up on my
website
uh sue archer
is a new member
welcome to bruce baldwin uh always
appreciate bruce all bruces are welcome
here
um thank you to michael alquist
as well as nathan anderson all signing
up at jointpakman.com supporting the
stream and lastly thanks for the gifts
to austin muckin thaler
and desiree de long each gifting a
subscription on my website putting us at
37. today's goal is a hundred i believe
that we can do it i really do
and uh
oh also thanks to bowflex man and beth
graham
putting us at 39 a couple super chats
coming in love and sub oh no we already
read that one
iranian attempted to assassinate bolton
and american were sad they failed i
don't know how to analyze that
i don't remember that story ali reza
but i appreciate you being here and
appreciate your support
all right let's continue because i have
many many more things uh okay i'm gonna
do more detail on this tomorrow but here
are the punishments trump could face
so espionage act violation
fines in up to 10 years in prison this
is this is all hypothetical to be clear
concealment of documents possible fines
and up to three years in prison
and then obstruction of justice possible
fines and up to 20 years in prison so
theoretically if it was all maximum
sentences consecutive sentences
33 years is what um
trump is facing
okay
we'll leave it at that a lot still has
to happen all right i'm gonna show you
guys another beautiful triggering this
one took place on fox news fox news has
a show called the five this is a show
where they will often bring on a
right-wing nut in this case it's dan
bongino and they have them sit in the
middle
and then other people say things and use
language to communicate and that type of
thing
and jessica tarlov who i'm not like a
big jessica tarlov fan in the sense that
she's a completely generic democratic
sort of apologist advisor it's she's no
big deal you know okay but she's really
really good at this
um
they bring her on
to talk about the trump search warrant
and all these different things
and
i'll just play it okay let's just i'll
just play for you president has had to
comply with and why now because they
subpoenaed him in june and he did not
comply
no i'm not going to do that no i'm not
yeah you are he actually met with them
on june 3rd according to multiple yes
and then after that james bratt who was
the agent involved in this who bongino
has to talk over her that's the oh
because jessica tarlov is completely
correct
the only way bon jino can stick with
this is to talk over it they met with
them on june 3rd according to multiple
yes and then after that jay bratt who
was the agent involved in this who does
overseas it was six weeks it was six
weeks since the end of june and that was
the last communication
if it was so urgent
was there a subpoena did you see degan
mcdowell trying to pull the exact
talking point i just told you all about
if it was so urgent why did they wait so
long on the one hand they're like well
he complied but
if there's so much urgency why were they
waiting so long but you they want to
have it both ways ignored by the trump
they had conversations after the
subpoena multiple conversations
they handed over right meaning they gave
him every opportunity
surveillance tapes just don't know
whether they comply it or not
so that's pretty good
and then um
bongino brings up hillary and jessica
tarlov rightly ridicules it check this
out on the democrat side hillary clinton
literally
[Laughter]
oh god nine minutes in hillary clinton
it's on the democrat side hillary
clinton literally paid a foreign spy
paid a
foreign about this and you're citing the
democrat party as a paragon don't make
me laugh i i i just love it
this isn't she's not like super
progressive i love jessica tarlov's
politics or anything but she's really
good in these situations really really
good
and yeah hillary derangement syndrome is
not
an altogether uh incorrect term for what
is going on here absolutely
uh let's see if cnn is back to the
documents themselves that not yet
apparently not yet
uh [ __ ] who the hell knows what's going
on on fox news
i don't even think fox news knows what's
going on
parents as we wait oh my god look at
this president mike huckabee's education
company this is not a joke guys this is
a real commercial greatest achievements
during his first term that's why we're
giving away the kids guide to president
trump
we've really got to protect children
from liberal indoctrination guys
accomplished for america what's more
it's part of a very special gift bundle
that includes a free kids magazine and a
free video we can't allow teachers to
teach transgender get them this instead
calm that's freetrumpguide.com
anyway all right so that's that's
happening there and it's you really you
really couldn't write this stuff that's
absolutely correct
i want to say thank you to some old dude
for gifting five subscriptions on
youtube that puts us at 44 over on
twitch thanks to scott 14 for the twitch
prime subscription and on our website i
want to say thanks to jim bruin for
signing up
i want to say thank you also to the
following people for gifting
subscriptions amanda huggin kiss
kyoko from tokyo kyoko with another gift
and kyoko with another gift
and lydia shepherd has sent a gift
subscription and also thank you to laura
maurer
that is six putting us at 51.
i think we can do the hundred i really
do
sarah says facts matter thank you david
for bringing the facts front and center
your show is amazing thank you sarah i
appreciate you
and also thanks to robert angel
for the
um
super chat
very very much appreciate that let me
just get some things cleaned up so we
can continue moving on to other
materials here
oh also thank you to gat
and ratifa
who
signed up via twitch prime as well all
right let's continue looking at some
other things you guys want to hear how
magats have been reacting to the news of
the search warrant
any interest in hearing from a few
magats including ones that
make up words that's one of my favorite
things when they make up words i
absolutely love it
this guy
is sick and tired
of the rigor morse
around what democrats are doing the
rigor morse it absolutely
must
stop
all right check it out
all about jealousy let's be honest
robert tassie shared the same sentiment
have you seen the documents to prove it
on a reasonable doubt that these deaths
is a true statement or is another
political bunch of rigor morse to make
him look even worse i i would even go
further
i would say it's flaccid morse i don't
even think there's any rigor to it to be
totally frank guys if i'm honest with
you
i don't even think so was this a
portmanteau of some kind of rigor mortis
and rigmarole
is that possible that that's what this
was
i don't know
i don't know it's all very very weird
um let's hear from another one
fox news actually had the
interest they they had the willingness
to go to mar-a-lago
and to interview some people there
do we dare
do we dare let's listen what is your
view on the fbi and why they decided to
raid uh the former president's property
i think they're just a mafia you know
being uh ordered by rey and after the
their they were ordered by christopher
ray yeah
known
trump antagonist christopher wray
appointed to be fdi the fbi director by
christopher wray
by trump brother
doesn't make a lot of sense
doesn't make a lot of sense this man
our ex-president for so long they're
trying to find any kind of dirt they can
pull up on him this is insane
i never see this happening when i stay
by then has to go to jail
hunter is the one fbi has to go and get
it right guys
why aren't they raiding hunter
why aren't they raiding killery
and most importantly why aren't they
raiding barack obama
right
that's what this is really about we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
yeah
so
that's that
and then we've got a couple more of
these interviews
uh
oh man this is actually getting pretty
depressing and that's basically i mean
it's been going on now for over six
years ever since they came down the
escalator they've been after they love
that phrase they ever since i came down
the escalator they'll never go
ever since that day when he came down
the escalator and implied most mexican
immigrants are rapists and murderers
ever since that day they've been going
after him they'll never mention that
that part of it
it's just the escalator after him
yesterday was the ultimate we've never
seen anything like that my life i
believe that they're trying to make it
so he cannot run i think they're trying
to attack the american people and
they're trying to go after the person
who put us first and put our american
godly values first that's why i believe
they're going known religious
figure
donald trump
who
obviously is not religious they are
referring to him as the most godly
figure listen to the delusion of that
what she just said
the american people and remember that
early on the evangelicals knew trump
wasn't religious they didn't want to go
anywhere near him they eventually
acquiesced
because there was sort of this
inevitability like we we don't
definitely don't want hillary so i guess
we're going for trump they're trying to
go after the person who put us first and
put our american godly values first
that's why i believe they're going after
him to intimidate us as americans
yep
just outrageous out completely and
totally in a fantasy world
i mean there there's no talking sense to
those folks there's it's just not
possible it's not possible
um
oh god look at this wanting to hang on
for it because they've wrapped some sort
of their identity around it for whatever
reason
but um
yeah i think that the vast majority of
people are are past it now and just want
to live their lives and not think about
it you know we had your tweet here
about governor gretchen whitmer and it's
saying she is positive with covid during
our broadcast to date a little bit of
breaking news with stacey okay yeah just
get me out of it so so so passive i want
to say thanks to rich sutt
muse
and twinner for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 56. also big
thank you to natalie clemenson who just
signed up on my website joinedpakman.com
and thanks to eamon barrett who just
gifted a membership at jointpakman.com
putting us at 58 for the day which is
absolutely fantastic let's listen to a
couple voicemails that are coming in not
going to do a ton of these
but i do want to
just listen to um a couple of these
let's see what we can find here
david this is really exciting 30 years
five years but i don't think people are
interested in the prison time i think
what they want to know will he be barred
from running for office again well we
have to wait and see
we don't know the answer to that yet
thanks to vj for the 50
super chat very much appreciate that vj
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails here
david jeremy from virginia
so i've been thinking recently um what
what would happen
as far as the conspiracy theorists go
when the day comes that
um
trump passes away
especially if it's sudden um i feel like
there's just no way
that they will not think there's some
sort of conspiracy there oh my god
when that day comes that trump dies
just you wait just you wait
until you it's going to be like jfk paul
mccartney moon landing it's it's going
to be absolutely nuts
you have no idea
it's going to be crazy
do we do we dare go to whitney and see
if whitney has something to say
let's see
so i just think that living life
for well
i'm gonna get stuff when i'm dead
is like kind of unhealthy like just the
thought process that goes into that yeah
um
i think that freedom of religion is very
artistic
but if i was going to define mental
health
uh doing stuff for like getting lots
when i die when there is no evidence
that you're going literally anywhere it
seems practically insane
um
but you know there's lots of other
things that make you totally crazy as
well
um wanting to live like a modest life
i don't think is crazy just because it's
like
over here you know like
might as well like
get something out of life all right so
there's that very very important um
let's see what else i have here
david sir
love the show
um
i feel like uh trump though everything
he's going through
[Music]
i feel like it's all not gonna
amount to anything
you know his base they'll say either
you know it's all fraudulent it's the
radical democrats going after him in the
first place or
if he took classified documents oh well
he was president he's still secretly
president he's gonna be president again
you know he doesn't pay taxes he's just
a savvy businessman yeah listen they're
gonna say all of that stuff and they've
already said even crazier stuff than
that so i don't think we can go by what
they're going to say uh they're always
going to say completely bonkers stuff
all right let's check out another clip i
have here this is really something else
devin nunes was interviewed this morning
on fox news by maria bartoromo maria
bartoromo as normal as she normally does
screaming her questions at devin nunes i
count eight conspiracy theories that
devin nunes mentions in this short clip
in reaction to the search warrant served
at mar-a-lago okay
try try to play along and count them for
me
i believe he mentions eight different
conspiracy theories conspiracy theories
here so so devin nunes you came out with
the nunes memo in 2018 and exposed all
of them uh is it the same documents that
they want to have under lock and key
that they wanted to get from trump's
home
well look i don't think we know that
because i'm not sure they even got a
whole lot of documents anyway they
haven't even accounted for them but
maria i would only disagree with cash i
don't normally disagree with cash but i
think this actually goes back pre-russia
gate hoax okay
this doesn't go back pre-russia gate
hoax this has to do with things donald
trump did in 2021
and the russia gate hoax wasn't really a
hoax in that 34 individuals and three
corporations were indicted
more money was recovered
than what the investigation cost
and the report was unable to clear
donald trump of obstruction
so we are two conspiracy theories in
even though nunes has been talking for
seven seconds i think this goes back to
the irs scandal where they targeted
conservatives that there is no such skin
so third conspiracy theory the irs
scandal where they targeted
conservatives
it turns out they didn't target
conservatives
the search phrases that were used to
look at possible tax cheats
included words that would find both left
and right wing organizations
in terms of the actual audits done there
was no bias in favor of auditing
conservatives so
third conspiracy theory from devin nunes
remember the question is about
trump having documents
at or near his toilet i think it goes
back to
fast and furious during the obama
administration where they ran guns and
tried to set people up you remember
innocent americans ended up getting
killed okay fast and furious is a name
for a program where they would allow
some guns to be trafficked rather than
stopping all of them in order to
basically try to find
the path that these guns were taking in
order to arrest more people you can say
it was a bad idea a couple people were
ultimately killed with some of those
guns that's true
but it has absolutely nothing to do with
this nothing whatsoever it goes back to
benghazi they got away with that nobody
got away with anything on benghazi
benghazi was a tragedy
the volume is low on this video i
apologize i've turned it up as much as i
can let me see if i can even crank it
more
um
there were 11 hearings about benghazi
hillary testified for eight hours or
longer i mean it just it has nothing to
do with this whatsoever nobody got away
with anything and then you have to
remember it was late 2015 or 16 that we
get to the plan where the the clinton
campaign working with dirty cops at doj
and fbi and the media i must say where
they set up to spy on the trump campaign
and ultimately republicans and frame an
innocent man okay that also didn't
happen
the people he listed weren't involved in
that
what happened was that the trump
campaign
had so many contacts with people who
were under fbi surveillance
that when the trump people
would call these other individuals they
were incidentally recorded right signals
intelligence because they were dealing
with so many people under fbi
surveillance that's the story
hillary didn't spy on trump's campaign
but they'll keep repeating it they'll
keep i've lost track honestly was that
the fifth or sixth conspiracy theory in
this clip
i i've genuinely lost count now
anybody remember
that was the fifth
oh that was that was fifth okay all
right let's continue the thin led to
what so that was the russia hoax that
then led to the mueller witch hunt so
all of this stuff is intertwined and
then you just fast forward you know none
of it is intertwined
mention you know the whitmer case and
jan six and whether or not federal
agents were involved in that okay that's
the conspiracy theory that the fbi
orchestrated or instigated the january
six trump riots
that's there's also no evidence of that
um some right-wingers have focused on
some guy i don't even remember the guy's
name web or any you guys remember what
the name is of the guy that they claim
is an fbi
agent that was instigating
i don't remember that guy's name it's
just another conspiracy theory the idea
that the fbi ray epps exactly thank you
mob father
um
it's another conspiracy theory so we're
up to six or seven so far
so you just stair step and then
ultimately this leads to what this leads
to a lot of stupidity is all this leads
to you've never done in american history
before you had a president's home
ransacked okay that's not a conspiracy
theory but it's very stupid which is we
this has never been done to a president
before
um
everything happens for the first time
sometime
i mean we've never had a president who
did the things trump did
we've never had a president to my
knowledge
flushing things down his toilet 10 times
15 times
we've never the fact that this hasn't
happened is a very silly talking point
trump nothing like trump has ever
happened before
by the same goons that were involved in
all of this and i would say that that
you know a lot of people have criticized
you know the the fbi and the doj and i
think rightfully so but someone are
making these calls and i would say that
the people that have been involved in
all those scandals that i just listed
yeah most of those were not actually
scandals are the very same people that
are now in charge of the doj and are at
the white house so that's almost like a
deep state type thing
like the same elite overlords
orange were involved in all these things
fast and furious
the russia probe
benghazi
um i i don't even know all the other
things so
it's crazy
i mean it's genuinely nuts that he's
squeezing in so many different
conspiracy theories
into the exact
same clip where he was just asked about
trump and the search warrant
he didn't mention when obama used fancy
mustard that that did not come through
yeah fortunately
uh did i see the man uh hear about the
man that drove to the capitol barrier
and shot himself i did hear about that
today
um
a 99
and
super chat from nina thank you nina who
says all this proves you have to vote
blue in every election for women's
rights especially love your show
nina with a very powerful declaration
thank you nina i really appreciate that
also want to say thank you to the mob
father who just grabbed the twitch prime
subscription i do want to say something
serious about twitch
as you can see above my head we're
currently over 2200 active twitch
subscribers
we haven't been at that level i want to
say for years quite literally years i
believe we've been on twitch three years
right now
um maybe it's two maybe three anyway
we have never
i don't know if we've ever been at 2244
but it's certainly been a very very very
long time so i appreciate that to
everybody watching on twitch i also
appreciate everybody supporting on the
website let me say thank you to dan
cevigne
carlos whitehouse
matthew james
and
thomas samoski
zamajski who just signed up at my
website
also thanks to eamon barrett
and someone else sent a gift
stanley minarik thank you stanley each
gifting a subscription putting us at 65.
if you're just tuning in
we are not like the daily wire
that has all these big investors and
massive dumps of money we actually
depend on the support of people in the
audience and when you sign up at
joinpakman.com
cents of every dollar
gets to us because we just pay two
percent to swipe credit cards that's it
all these other platforms they slice and
they swipe
and it's really a shame
and it never should have happened so we
really appreciate that and you can you
don't have to pay full price the coupon
code indict will save you massively
massively massively and it's absolutely
tremendous let's get to oh hold on no i
actually do want to listen to this they
reportedly got a false written statement
that all the classified was released and
then they had to uh
do a search warrant in order to get
these uh classified documents
it just doesn't hold up there's i was in
charge of these rules in the white house
i explained them to the then president
and vice president everybody from on
down these are very serious rules
because the information goes to our
national security kate one last point
the president's statement today about
the attorney-client and executive
privilege documents to me that's a hint
that what might have been collected
relates not just to these alleged
document crimes but to the other
investigations of uh obstruction of an
official proceeding in congress and of
uh conspiracy to defraud the united
states those are the kinds of documents
that the january 6 committee has been
fighting with the former president of
speculative so we'll see but he may have
tipped his hand that there is more here
that could incriminate him
scott you mentioned that
that you believe that the president got
a temporary at least temporary boost
with um the former president got a
temporary boost when
as this all happens because people were
republicans were quick to jump to his
defense but you also say that in your
mind this can only end in one of two
ways either former president trump has
to get indicted or merrick garland has
to resign when i heard you say that i
was wondering why is why is this why are
there only two ways out of this in such
an extreme way
there's no going back now i mean we're
all at the circus now we're under the
big top and merrick garland's gonna have
to produce a clown on stilts juggling
flaming bowling pins at this point i
mean we're here we're waiting they have
taken the unprecedented step of raiding
the home of a former president and
probable candidate
and they have said to the world we think
maybe this guy violated a little
hyperbolic pause not including the laws
they might be investigating him for on
january the 6th at this point how do you
go back how do you put the toothpaste
back in the tube if you don't indict him
now you basically will open up the
department of justice's credibility here
for an attack that's like well i guess
you did it for political purposes i i to
me
the credibility of the bureau and of the
department of justice is on the line the
steps they've taken
so bold to go after these documents and
to accuse possibly the president of a
former president of violating these laws
i i just don't know how you the rubicon
is crossed how do you go back
i think i mean if we're talking about
credibility clearly the credibility of
the former president is also on the line
here with what he said
gentlemen it's good to see you thank you
thanks kate
so police they are investigating an
incident that occurred near yeah so
that's that's i mean listen
i don't know that it's indictment or
merit garland resigns
but there is no doubt that if it's just
like yeah no turns out trump didn't do
anything wrong
but we got our documents back
it will be a disaster for the justice
department i completely agree with that
and i agree with what scott jennings
says that a rubicon certainly has been
crossed
there's no doubt about that
um other super chats coming in kevin
says hey david can you talk about the
build back better bill that was passed
are my fears unfounded that everyone's
health care costs will rise to offset
the losses companies take due to
medicare caps
i have to look more closely at that
question
but
there's a couple different ways that
that can go we've talked about this
three pronged
sort of
reality about healthcare
and cost and access and quality
i will follow up on it when i look at it
more deeply
do you think the trump cult will ever
transfer their loyalty to another leader
like desantis or will they forever stay
with trump terrifying really good
question elizabeth i don't know the
answer i think we will get a sense
if trump runs but loses in 2024
we will find out do the trumpists bail
on the general
if trump runs but loses the primary in
24 and someone else wins do the
trumpists even vote in the general or
are they done with politics because they
really only cared about trump
we may actually figure that out
i don't know the answer at this point in
time
but it's something we may figure out
thank you to jamlock for gifting two
subscriptions on twitch as well as
aurora fck
matt breckley
and day yoshi
that puts us at 71 for the day
which is an extraordinary number
cody says your linguist breakdown of
matt walsh question if you enjoy
linguist stuff check out the book don't
sleep there are snakes people with
weapons claiming the irs is coming to
take people's weapons on tick-tock
lunatics
that's a lot cody give me some time to
look into it all
but that's certainly a lot
certainly certainly a lot
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails that have been coming in
let's listen
hi david this is stephen i was calling
to ask with all the investigations going
on with trump and the severity of these
is trump
allowed right now to be able to travel
yeah and if
he tried to make a travel do you think
that they would actually
make a big scene and he talked about it
uh thank you so much david bye
like if trump was seen i mean here's the
thing trump generally speaking no trump
travels by private plane
it is interesting to think about if in
the midst of this imagine like the
dominique strauss khan thing where
dominique strauss khan was quite
literally pulled off of a plane about to
fly to france from jfk
and then charged
um if trump was seen boarding a plane to
you know hungary or
russia or something
would it become an international
incident it's an unrealistic thing
because he travels by private plane and
so often you know you would
and different planes also
so he would have to be under some kind
of either indictment there there may be
you know sometimes law enforcement can
tell you to stick around
even though you're not indicted i don't
know legally what the deal is with that
i can't really say i'm they could take
your passport of course and then
but can they take your passport if
you're not if you've not been indicted i
just don't know
just imagine right imagine
um i don't know the answer to that but
it is it is a very very interesting
question for sure
david this is harrison from los angeles
just calling in because in light of the
recent trump news
it would be really great to hear the
opinion and takes of some legal experts
i was wondering if you might be able to
uh invite some legal experts on your
show indeed to discuss it
thanks
we should be able to wrangle some legal
experts absolutely more on that this
week
hey david i just wanted to say that um
this trump cult
and that's exactly what it is we know it
at this point just based on what you see
from
some of his followers when they're
interviewed that this this almost
hypnosis that they're under when it
comes to trump um should
shouldn't they be considered at this
point of a terrorist organization
because the i mean the perpetual threats
of violence showing listen i don't know
that you can get first of all it's not
really an organization if you're a trump
supporter you're not really in an
organization
oh i i think that it's a cult i don't
know about i think
i think terrorism it's it's a sickness
it's a
cult um
oh wow
somebody just got banned after only
oh they followed 12 minutes ago okay
that's not bad we've had people banned
within one minute
12 minutes actually isn't that crazy
we've we've seen we've seen much much
worse
um
[Music]
chris says i know father duties come
before game time when's the next chess
tournament i don't have any chess
tournament to announce what i do have is
we are going to be doing
a members only town hall
on
wednesday august 31st at 6 pm eastern
this one is going to be members only
we're still going to do the regular town
halls as well everybody relax
but we are going to be doing a members
only town hall
on august 31st which i think is going to
be pretty crazy should be pretty nuts
keep up the good work david says daniel
thank you
joe says happy birthday to my wonderful
wife lisa we're celebrating in duluth
and happy for the stream after walking
19 000 steps today beautiful let's see
where am i at
i'm at 10 000 steps today yeah i find
that when i travel last time i was in la
i was walking like 22 000 steps a day it
was crazy
kratos orion says i would love it if we
create a precedent that no person is
above the law that's especially
important in the case of a president
former or not i agree completely
i couldn't agree more
absolutely well said i want to say thank
you to adable and g hammond for the
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
73. also thank you to andreas crockneys
for signing up at joinedpakman.com
joinpacman.com
the website is working and we are
currently accepting
new members accepting new members all
right let's get to a couple other things
here
that i had for you
um
not the dominoes thing
yeah i have a lot of these pictures of
these standouts of the trump people
hanging out outside mar-a-lago i mean
it's basically what you can imagine
i i you know you can use your
imagination you know what it is
um the christian hate preacher greg
locke who we've covered before
he had thoughts about the search warrant
listen to this
i'm telling you
all they want to do is control the
narrative
that's what this mar-a-lago nonsense is
about they want to humiliate president
trump uh-huh notice i didn't call him
former president trump either
that's exciting to the to the literal
circus tent church-goers
they trying to humiliate him
[Applause]
yeah
so that's that
um here's another while we're doing our
tour of evangelical crazy churches here
is pastor ed young today
like any cult though they're cults out
there they take terms that we're
very very familiar with
they redefine them
a definition that that i've come up with
after reading a lot of brilliant
christian thinkers and also
atheistic thinkers who are non-woke
here is what i've come up with what is
locism it's an authoritarian worldview
that seeks to deconstruct the
foundations of our christian faith by
overwhelming overpowering and
overthrowing those who
do not adhere to its ideology
wow
who defined that
that's
that's pretty heavy
if i define what gives them in one word
paganism
let's throw out some names
karl marx
who goes to this crap
frederick
nietzsche
whoa sigmund
freud
and we will ban men
so uh
yeah
that's going on
uh
let me see if i had anything else here
on my list
i mean i guess just to be thorough let's
do one more conspiracy theory this is
pastor greg locke
what what they just did more logo
boralago
that's a prophetic warning
do you know what we tried to do for
months and years
sound coherent
we have tried every way imaginable as
the american people
to arm
train veterans
to sit in our public schools
and keep our kids from getting shot up
yikes and they won't do it
they won't even arm or train veterans
to protect our kids but you know what
they go and do
they hire and arm 87 000 irs workers
because the middle class american might
be making a hundred dollars too much
every year we got to make sure that
they're doing their taxes right bunch of
thieves yeah i mean listen the focus is
going to be people making
i thought it was over
5 million a year or something like that
um
this guy's really dangerous
you hear me you're a bunch of thieves
you're a bunch of lion devils you're a
bunch of demon possessed crooks
i ain't scared no stupid fbi i scared no
irs we don't revoke all that nonsense
anyhow
i can burn their 501 c3 for all i care i
don't want it i don't need it i ain't
worried about none of you didn't we
learn this guy's church isn't even a
non-profit or something like that i'm
trying to remember he he plays coy with
that
i don't care if the take me 501. but i
thought people investigated it and he
didn't even he like he was he gave it up
or something like that does anybody in
the chat remember that
anyway
show up here with your stupid armed irs
agents all you want to we ain't backing
down for your godless democratic
nonsense you hear me
[Applause]
just make sure you hear me it's totally
normal i get this video that your body
they bout to steal your money out of
your bank account
they burning this nation to the ground
we sitting around fiddling while rome's
burning well our preacher's just a
little bit too bold
i ain't even started yet oh it's a manic
episode oh i got it okay i didn't
realize it it's mania yep
all right well that's that's that um
youtube viewer asked sir david what do
you make of the people's convoy rump
rebranded the 1776 restoration movement
that protests outside of the dc jail
where the january 6 prisoners are held a
very confused sad individuals is how i
would very succinctly sum it up
have i spoken with sarah kenzer author
of hiding in plain sight i i interviewed
her previously i've not spoken with her
recently jeff
but i would i would be interested in
having her back on to be totally frank
i want to say thank you to ms lolal
who just signed up via twitch prime and
his new member number 75 today also a
big thank you
to juan who just gifted a membership and
thomas mangum who just got himself a
membership putting us at 77. very very
uh much appreciated and lastly thanks to
jm gray for the twitch prime
subscription
putting us at 78. folks we are
dangerously close to a hundred
let's do this we're getting down to the
end of this stream
if we hit the hundred
i'll commit to another stream this week
which was not guaranteed because i'm
getting up to
the thing i've been talking about in
montreal is happening this week
there is no guarantee
andrea says cpac reminded me of the most
extreme participants in some fringe tv
channels in my native norway
but they receive like a few thousand
views max right cpac has massive
audience
that's the difference
and that makes it very
very
very scary
extraordinarily scary
um
and it's not likely to stop because they
are really good at putting together
those events
here's another voicemail about the
search warrant
hi david i would like to think of myself
as a very rational thinking person
but i
i see something
and and maybe i'm totally left-field
about it but maybe not
the thing is
donald trump
had nuclear documents and classified
documents at model argo allegedly
yeah we all know he shouldn't have
violation of the law
and i'm seeing
um
the fact that
it's just not clicking on the other side
like the republicans just just don't
want to believe that this is possible
there has to be some sort of other
explanation
it's someone else's fault
you know
i'm a big fan of accountability
and so to me when you do something and
you screwed up just admit it and move on
i agree and it seems like they just
refused to do that
that's all i have to say i i really i
mean admitting it might involve jail
time in this particular case but i i
understand the point for sure
but you know easier said than done
jamie asking emotional burnout after row
i mean no now you know it
it's okay
uh at an individual level it's a
horrifying thing horrifying things
happen to the country a lot
um but we're covering it and we're still
here and doing doing our thing i mean i
think there's always sort of a this is
why it's good to take time off from
politics to some degree
um
but we got to keep going we can't just
bail you know
apologies if this was brought up says
jack how do you feel about jim acosta's
recent interview of andrew yang i didn't
see it i did see i should that sounds
interesting i should check that out um
by the way this continues to be kind of
funny to me
dems pass spending bill with economy in
turmoil okay we still have high
inflation but it's coming down
gas price is down for over over 60 days
full employment
wages up
jobs report double the expected number
of jobs stock market looking pretty good
consumer demand off the charts
which metric is it that they are
pointing to
inflation which is coming down right i
mean i don't let's see if we can even
figure it out
of the federal reserve this time around
i would say bad policy resulted in bad
outcomes
one of the most popular hosts in all the
television certainly on fox maria
bartoromo thank you for sharing your
expertise oh wait trey gowdy is
interviewing her what the hell is going
on here thank you for carving out time
for us i hope you have a great weekend
thank you trey
yes ma'am
coming up the midterms are coming but
the expectations game has already
started martha mccallum helps us look
toward the fall with a special eye on
the united what on earth is happening on
fox what what a terrible terrible show
dear god
i want to say thanks to jason sickmeyer
as well as terry schwerin
rodolfo inahosa
number 7980 and 81 today also thanks to
jen here for the gifted twitch
subscription putting us at 82
and another membership from rodolfo
putting us at 83. a couple other super
chats coming in i've been waiting for
someone to connect the dots between
trump's previous impeachments and
investigations mueller said he found
russians tried messing with zelensky
those documents are made for russia
north korea china
interesting
i'm going to have to research that a
little more but it sounds it sounds very
interesting
couple other voicemails let's see what
else we have here
hey david guy young from brookdale
illinois
uh i know fc cup okay i think she's on
face to nation or something on msnbc and
once again
she repeats
that the democrats should not expect
the far far right
uh candidates for different positions
uh
and i've seen her write this to it in a
in the paper sometimes we get achieved
kind of calm and every week she writes
something and although i like her now
for because she used to be a real real
all right i can read ahead and see that
that one's not really going anywhere i i
do appreciate it let's hear from billy
harrison
david pac-man this is uh billy harrison
here oh
i just watched one of your uh
clips or videos on youtube
and it was uh
what is a woman you making fun of matt
walsh
you cannot i actually i don't know that
i mentioned matt walsh even even once in
that video
where you
referenced
an apple defined apple and you said
there's so many other fruits that can
define as an apple
so you mean to tell me you're that
[ __ ] stupid to where if i say hey
david hand me an apple out of the
refrigerator
you bring me a cucumber or cantaloupe
or root beer
or the whole refrigerator right so billy
didn't understand the commentary the
point was
even though it's not easy
to define common nouns in a way that
really would allow someone who doesn't
know what it is to figure out like the
whole point was
if i say define an apple
i can say well
you know it's the fruit of the rose tree
right but then it's kind of circular
because you get still got to know what a
roastery is what it looks like
if you say well it's
a fruit with seeds and like a stem
and it could be red yellow orange or red
red yellow orange or green
uh and it's like a sweet or but
sometimes it's tart
right it doesn't actually help us
so
the whole point was
societally
we can say hey get me an apple
and the other person knows what it is
nobody actually has to define it and the
definition is context dependent like the
big apple or apple the company etc
the
the clip was exactly for someone like
billy and he didn't get it
and you can't bring me an apple because
you can't you there's so many other
things to define as apple
all right
the whole point was that the definition
is quite irrelevant that's the point and
billy seems to be making the point by
saying
if you ask for an apple i don't need the
definition right that's that's exactly
the point billy
that is exactly the point
man it's
it's really tough out there i mean i
think he thinks he made a really good
point that's the scary thing
very scary
hey david this is cody culp my phone's
dying i apologize if you hear the but
the i think it probably just sounds like
something blank on your end cutting into
the line
i just loved your video uh the
on the uh matt walsh what is a woman the
linguistic side of it uh linguistics is
fascinating uh
i was gonna suggest a book to you uh
it's called don't sleep there are snakes
by daniel everett it's a
missionary who went down
to like the south to south america to
try and learn a tribe's uh language so
he could interpret the bible yes it's
been recommended to me and it is it
appears very interesting i will agree
with that i want to say thank you to
walking tacos yakum's taser
and mr hum dinger for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 86. over on
the website i want to say thanks to
um jeremy broadbeck who just signed up
and then a bunch of gifted memberships
one from andrew kulp
one from jason sickmeyer one from tommy
horswell and one from blake daniel
that's five putting us at 91
and on that note that gets us to the end
of my time for today
i'm glad that everybody was able to join
me today on the rare sunday stream
we have a chock-full packed podcast
tomorrow
and i hope every single one of you
is going to go ahead and get tomorrow's
show globalished internationalist
trotskyite socialist shun like obama
trudeau macron and the rest of these zio
beasts
all right everybody see you tomorrow
thank you
you